did you know uh rogan at all before you
did the pod no i just hung out with him
that week leading up to it because you
were i was in austin doing shows
at uh i recorded my special in up did
you before i did rogan where did you
record the special uh in austin at the
creek
oh creek that's freaking out yeah yeah
yeah
yeah have you done the vulcan yet i did
it's got a slipknot concert yeah yeah
it's a little there's like metal and
people standing up all right have you
done a vulcan yet no it's good it's good
it's good for for like if you walked in
there and saw that room you'd be like
this is going to be a [ __ ] disaster
because it's a rock room it's like it's
made for it's like music it's a musical
for like tall ceilings so it's like
there's like yeah literally that was my
joke i was like feeling that i was like
i feel like i'm in a [ __ ] slipknot
concert like there's like metal
everywhere that's tough it's in but
people are standing and there's couches
yeah and then after we were performing
it turns into like a rave show like goes
on yeah like people are waiting to get
in the door to [ __ ] do drugs and
lick each other's ass that's weird wow
yeah but yeah they've it's a good club
though they did make it good like it
shouldn't be what about where it
shouldn't work so the creek in the cave
is uh what is that is that a comedy club
yeah it was in new york
and they moved it to austin so now
austin's going to open cap cities rogan
has a place quick in the cave there's a
lot of venues now yeah also be a github
oh yeah did you ever think about moving
during this whole no covert [ __ ] no i
just moved to new york
and like i just got in at the seller
so there's no reason to i'm gonna stay
at the seller yeah the seller's really
good yeah oh yeah yeah it's it's dude
it's so good i just did that buffalo
with dove david off and the stand by the
way yeah shout out to the stuff
too yeah
yeah yeah he's around it's it's great
and it's just like
it's hard to bomb did you get very hard
did you get passed on the first try
first uh i had a weird
way of getting past because i auditioned
like kind of before covet and then covet
happened so i actually auditioned like
before snl a little bit and then i got
canceled
and they're like
and then i got and then covet happened
so there was like really no window for
me to even audition and then uh they
just called and were like send us your
veils
out of nowhere you've probably talked
about this before who called you to tell
you you weren't on snl uh
lauren and like a man like a lady and
then lauren
i could leave that represents that
anytime you talk to lauren somebody
would call him be like michael's on the
line was he cool i like i like learn a
lot yeah i still do was it your i'm sure
again i'm sure you've talked about this
that's fine
have uh was it your dream to do saturday
live like was that maybe in like seventh
grade when it was but then once i
started doing stand-up i was like this
is
yeah i knew i i figured i would never be
on snl
like ever because i've seen it yeah
lately and i know what i do yeah you
know yeah it's fair you think it's a
blessing in disguise that all this
happens sure
you guys here's what i said what else
you gonna do though you know what i'm
saying like you yeah
you could sulk on it and of course
that's yeah what could you do should i
quit but but i i gotta be honest it's
one of the reasons i think
a lot of people rallied around because
everyone's like definitely the [ __ ]
we've all said stupid [ __ ] yeah you know
but there's also like uh
like there's i think if i would have got
snl i think i could have done very well
on it i agree you had a good career that
way 100 and now that i got cancelled
from it or however you want to say it
yeah uh
i think that i that is also a good
opportunity so i would say
i would rather it have happened
than not at all you know what i mean
yeah you know like if i just never got
snl and never got either way i think
it's put you on them yeah yeah for sure
yeah and i think
uh
yeah i'm alright i'm comfortable having
eyes on
me
with my what i'm creating well you're
creating you're like i'm not afraid to
i'm not worried about a spotlight on
what i make
no but but that makes sense no it makes
sense if i sucked and got canceled that
would be a tough huge problem you want
to have a career yeah that would be a
major issue but i think too it's like
you know the fans that rallied around
you and then
they brought all this attention to you
those are the people that [ __ ] with you
like those are your actual fans instead
of like
they're not all shane gillis fans sure
now you're building a real fan base
there's a downside
but you're also playing like when you're
on the road now you're playing home
games sure you get your fans you can
[ __ ] around like you're special
you know if you're just a live fan you
turn into let's say you're on there and
you turn in your stress like jesus
christ shane went hard in the pain yeah
your fans are like [ __ ] yeah that would
have been a pain you know what i'm
saying but it was all it's also there is
a downside that like immediately when
you get canceled there are a lot of
people that you don't want as a fan yeah
yeah oh yeah i gotta have guys coming up
to me after shows and like screaming
slurs yeah i'd be like hell yeah be like
i don't think you get it yeah yeah
thank you can you take that shirt off
yeah
if you're gonna do that
yeah i think people rallied around you
because
most people are not comfortable and
shouldn't be with the idea that you said
something in passing
in a certain context
like in a conversation and your whole
life should not be erased for that sure
your opportunity which is a huge one in
snl which very few people get shouldn't
be taken away yeah and that is the world
yeah and i think everyone would agree
including myself that it wasn't great
yeah my what i said yeah yeah but uh
yeah i think the punishment didn't
really match the correct agreement and
that's where everyone was like all right
maybe chill
but and i also think the other yeah i
think that's the counter to council
culture it's like all right he said
something should have said
he lost his job and i think most humans
are like nah that ain't right man well
because you know they're tuned in right
and the other thing that's really
important to realize that when you do
cancel somebody like when they do that
to you
you're not making the world more
equitable you're actually not doing
anything it's not as though now you're
making
the world
more fair and more equal you're just
you're just kind of you're suppressing
it form of destruction you're
suppressing it making it worse yeah
i think the only real way to beat
whatever this is the cancel culture
thing is to just keep going yeah like
don't let it consume you like if i if i
got cancer and then spent the next two
years being like [ __ ] cancel culture
[ __ ] this i'm gonna stop rioting then
i'm not doing it then i'm not doing
that's how that's how you go
that's how you get cancer yeah i agree
you let that keep moving you keep
running i think you releasing the
special was kind of like yeah definitely
not cancelled